let's now do a sort of very early
evaluation of the Democratic primary so
far the big news of course that
Massachusetts Democratic senator
Elizabeth Warren is apparently running
for president she announced an
exploratory committee but she's been
exploring for a while
this basically means she's running right
now she's running against West Virginia
State Senator Richard O jeddah
who I interviewed on the program Andrew
yang running on universal basic income
who I interviewed on the program
Maryland Congressman John Delaney there
are probably others who have announced
but I'm not aware of them because
they're not prominent who Leon Castro
has launched an exploratory committee
but Elizabeth Warren is the most most
prominent candidate thus thus far by far
and what I want to do is briefly look at
her politics compared to those of Bernie
Sanders now you might say David why are
you comparing to Bernie Bernie's not
running well two reasons number one
Warren and Bernie are widely assessed as
the two most progressive Senators in the
Senate so looking at how their views
compare is important number two even
though you're right that Bernie hasn't
announced a 2020 campaign he ran in 2016
there's already talk of how Elizabeth
Warren could be the person with Bernie's
views in 2020 if Bernie doesn't run so
let's look at that and it's really
important to remind you although most of
you will understand this this is not a
segment to attack Bernie or Elizabeth
Warren I'm not gonna participate in
infighting I'm going to provide you
information and in a general election I
would vote for either Elizabeth Warren
or Bernie Sanders when I did my
political alignment quiz a couple of
months ago the two candidates with whom
I was most aligned politically were
Bernie number-one and very closely
behind Elizabeth Warren it was like 88
and 82 percent or something like that so
if and when Bernie announces we will
have plenty of time to look at the micro
differences between the two but here's
the main sort of distinguishing factor
or factors between Elizabeth Warren and
Bernie Sanders number one Bernie and
Warren represent different segments of
American political history they source
from very different political mindsets
even if
today their positions are very similar
on lots of issues Bernie is from the
sort of socialistic Jewish hippie wing
and raised in the world of unions and
civil rights organizing denouncing the
power of the rich and corporations for
the last however many decades Elizabeth
Warren comes from the world of law
school lawyers was a Republican in the
mid 90s is more about tweaking
capitalism than questioning it at some
kind of higher level it doesn't mean
that today Bernie's a communist and
Elizabeth Warren is straight up on
unregulated for unregulated capitalism
they both are sort of Social Democrats
today but what's important is that their
politics developed from very different
backgrounds when it comes to the economy
the way I summarize it is that Elizabeth
Warren is clearly a capitalist who wants
to inch toward social democracy in
reasonable ways whereas Bernie is more
of a Democratic Socialist at heart who
has tailored his politics towards social
democracy because he's a pragmatist they
end up in very similar places Warren
says let's tweak capitalism to give the
working class more power Bernie says I
will begrudgingly accept where
capitalism represents the underpinnings
of society but I'll do everything I can
to change the underlying reality of the
system when it comes to a sheet
achievable policy if they'll be very
close now I'll give you a couple of
examples as to how these differences
will actually manifest in policy in
different ways college education x'
elizabeth warren wants to keep the
system mostly the same but expand access
for low-income students Bernie wants to
make public college and university
tuition free okay that's a difference on
policy if you look at corporate power
and money Elizabeth Warren wants to
mandate that corporate boards have
worker representation Bernie wants to
straight-up limit corporations from
being able to get so big including
limiting the size of financial
institutions and that is a much bigger
undertaking you
debate the pragmatics you can debate the
morality but those are differences they
both end up supporting single-payer
supporting postal banking supporting
lots of the same policies but the theme
is Warren wants to restructure markets
to help workers Bernie wants to break
down the market system wherever possible
by either getting rid of the profit
motive or adding a public option the
source of all of this is that they both
believe the game is rigged they agree on
that there's a gap which a New Republic
article says is that Warren wants to
rewrite the rules and Bernie wants to
flip the board over sending the pieces
flying everywhere and I think that
that's a pretty apt analogy as the
campaign's develop if Bernie runs we are
going to have plenty of time to analyze
their platforms position by position but
the point today is both of these people
as candidates would be well in line with
my politics but they're not the same in
their worldview their underlying
philosophies do differ and that's not a
bad thing send me your thoughts about
Elizabeth Warren running about the
contrast with Bernie Sanders I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman and the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show today's
sponsor is Skillshare and I'm excited to
tell you that everybody in our audience
is getting two entire months of free
access to Skillshare when you click the
link underneath this video skill shares
the site that offers over 25,000 online
courses on almost any topic you can
imagine cooking meditation photography
video editing Photoshop managing a small
business almost an endless list and
whether you're trying to get ahead in
your career maybe you want to learn new
skills that will make you better at your
job you might just be exploring a new
hobby and you're trying to find new ways
to be creative in your personal time
skill shares the perfect place to fully
immerse yourself in whatever you're
trying to learn I really enjoyed the
class on more advanced video editing
techniques because it's something I've
been wanting to improve at but have been
very busy hosting the Dave
Packard show for the last few years once
again the David Pakman show is giving
you two whole months of access to every
single class offered by Skillshare after
those two months if you want to keep
your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than ten bucks a
month get better at whatever it is that
you're passionate about or discover
something brand new that you didn't even
know that you would love and join skill
shares other seven million users by
clicking the link underneath this video
[Music]